How is your modified Pearson different than the traditional Gerson?
So the traditional Gerson protocol is to do 13 glasses of juice every day.
So basically a glass of juice every week you know or for the most part doing five coffee
animals a day and then there's some nutritional pieces that were added to that too.
Gerson is from Max Gerson who wrote several very good books on cancer and highly recommend them.
But remember all his work with cancer patients was done back in the 1930s and 40s and 50s.
Charlotte has kept up his work on a marvelous basis. Well we have found with a Gerson protocol
first of all it can be juicing okay juicing and doing a Gerson protocol can be really good if your
cancer is not fed through glycolysis. So if it is fed through glycolysis if you're
juicing and care juicing it's very high in nutrient value but it's also very high in glucose.
So you can't really do a Gerson type protocol if your cancer is fed mainly through glycolysis.
The other issue that we have with Gerson is that it becomes very difficult to follow.
So we've had patients come in the office literally balling in tears that they feel so ashamed
that they cannot continue their Gerson protocol that they started prior to coming to us.
So can a Gerson protocol full protocol juicing 13 glasses a day doing five coffee
out of us be helpful. Yes I don't see that as real sustainable. You almost have to hire a maid
or have multiple extended family members, gooey grocery shopping for you, juicing for you,
just the physical ability to do that it limits everything else in life and if that's the last
you know Hail Mary pass that we have to try to save life that's great and to do that for a period
of time that might be necessary and it might be appropriate but in our clinic and in my life I'm
trying to balance you know healing with respect for that person and respect for the quality of
life they have. To me it's real easy to make an idol out of your healing if you are consumed with
the tasks that you have to do in a given day to hopefully heal from the cancer and doing a full
Gerson protocol can be life-consuming and it kind of defeats the purpose of why you want to heal the
cancer so that you can live life if you can't live life. Now I understand if I have to do this for three
months and this is going to give me another 10 years of life well going to say for all let's do
the three months of doing Gerson but it's not everybody that has that experience it could just be
draining on their life so it can be a good program for people it's not a good program for everybody
just like anything else and we want to make sure that we're not consumed and make an idol out of our
here or healing.